In Europe, we are facing
the worst energy crisis
in at least 50 years.
We compare this with the
first oil embargo in 1973,
but the current crisis
feels even worse than that
because this time, it's a
much wider energy crisis.
The crisis is really huge
in terms of the price.
The price impacts homes, businesses,
industries, and the economy.
We see energy prices
breaking record after record.
The consequences for households
and companies are not sustainable anymore.
We've got less customers coming in.
Our margins are smaller.
It's a perfect storm for disaster.
European economies, they are
on the brink of recession,
so the winter is going
to be tough around here.
Over the next few months,
Europe will face a high stakes puzzle,
how to keep the lights on
with a substantial portion
of its energy supply suddenly gone.
To do that, countries are going to need
to maneuver the balance of
supply and demand swiftly
and precisely and make hard decisions
about how to minimize the pain
of this winter and the next.
Beyond that, Europe could be forced
to reconsider its reliance on fossil fuels
in what some see as the beginning
of a fundamental transformation
of its energy system.
The old pattern of responding
to every fossil fuel crisis
with a grab for more fossil fuels
is simply not tenable anymore.
If there is to be a silver lining
from this terrible traumatic
year here in Europe,
it is that it has reset
the energy debate forever.
The history of Europe and
Russia on gas goes back
to the Cold War when Russia was not Russia
but the Soviet Union.
Slowly, Europe got in some ways addicted
to cheap Soviet and Russian gas.
It was plentiful, it was
affordable, was around the corner,
and it really became the backbone
of the European industrialization.
Europe uses gas for heating,
for industrial production,
as a feed stock, and as a energy source.
It uses gas for power production.
And natural gas is
really, really important
for these economies.
Flows of Russian gas to
Europe only increased
after Putin became president in 2000
and doubled down on Russian gas production
via the state owned
energy company, Gazprom.
It's this gasfield
but it's the basis for
Gazprom's power and wealth
and in turn Russia's revival
as a power on the world stage.
By 2021, the EU was getting more than 40%
of its natural gas imports from Russia.
But looming behind all that cheap energy,
there was a problem.
While Russian gas was
cheap, it was also a tool
for the Kremlin to exert
political and economic pressure.
In this particular crisis,
Vladimir Putin saw the
opportunity to use gas
as that tool to put pressure in Europe.
For a lot of people,
the energy crisis began
when Russia invaded Ukraine in February.
But for us in the energy
market, it began before that.
September, October of a year ago,
that's when Russia started
to reduce supply of gas.
Europe is facing a worsening energy crisis
ahead of winter.
Gas prices have reached record highs
and supplies are running
low across the block.
Russia blamed difficulties,
it blamed problems,
but surely, it was cutting
supply into Europe.
That meant that prices starting to go up,
reaching very soon record highs.
The situation got much worse into 2022,
particularly after the
invasion of Ukraine.
Air raid sirens in Kyiv,
signaling that the full scale invasion
of a European country was well underway.
We saw prices skyrocketing
because everybody was afraid
of how the battle would
actually impact infrastructure.
And then we started to see
the western countries imposing sanctions.
Putin chose this war,
and now, he and his country
will bear the consequences.
That's when we first
started seeing supply cuts
from Russia to European countries.
Some hope Russia would
continue exporting gas
to Europe in spite of the war.
But over the course of
the year, that hope faded.
Supplies were gradually cut
over the summer on Nord Stream,
the big gas pipeline that brings
fuel from Russia to Europe,
and then finally stopped.
And the market realized
that really those supplies
probably weren't going to come back.
By late August, natural gas futures spiked
to more than seven times what
they had been a year before.
Then, this happened.
Sabotage at sea.
That's what President
Biden is calling the leaks
and explosions on the
Nord Stream pipelines.
This is natural gas, highly
flammable natural gas
that is bubbling to the surface.
It remains unclear who carried
out the suspected sabotage
of the Nord Stream pipelines and why,
but the leaks sent an unmistakable message
about the vulnerability of
Europe's energy infrastructure.
It was seen as the start
of a new chapter in this energy war.
Everyone then thought, "What
if it's not a Russian pipeline
but it's a pipeline from Norway
into the European Union
bringing gas supply
from the Nord Stream?"
If that was hit,
Europe simply will not
have not nearly enough gas,
not even for the winter,
even for the fall.
Now, Europe is headed
into winter with sharply
reduced energy imports.
Whether some countries
will make it through
without severe power cuts
will depend on whether supply
and demand can be balanced
and on how cold it gets.
For some of the most vulnerable citizens,
the stakes could be life or death.
If we have more people unable
to afford to heat their homes
and sitting in the cold,
then experts expect
there to be more deaths.
Below 13 degrees Celsius
is when you can have heart problems.
You know, these are problems
that affect more the elderly
or people with existing conditions.
However, cold does kill people.
And it worries me for the economy,
you know, for the European economy.
You know, we have not enough energy,
rising interest rates, huge inflation.
Energy, this crisis has revealed,
is so integral to everything.
In hopes of averting
a worse case scenario,
European governments are taking action,
addressing both sides of the
dilemma, supply and demand.
On the supply side, it's
trying to grab as much gas
as they can find in the
international market,
particularly of liquified natural gas.
This is the big gas
carriers that shape gas
from places like Qatar
and the United States.
Liquified natural gas
has really been the hero.
We've seen a very strong flow
of LNG entering our ports,
in our terminals.
The problem is that
Europe now faces actually
a lack of infrastructure
to import that gas.
We can import gas from elsewhere,
but we are very limited by the amount
of LNG import facilities
that we have in place.
And at the moment across Europe,
there are 25 of these
facilities being planned.
We'll have the first couple this winter,
but through next year, we'll have more,
and that will definitely help.
But to really get imports scaled up,
new construction will be needed,
not just on the European side,
but on the US side as well.
One of the dates that people
look forward to is 2026
when a lot more US export
LNG capacity comes online.
That is a long time away
and that's the problem with
building infrastructure.
It takes time.
In the meantime, other more
contentious sources of energy
will have to make up the shortfall.
The energy crisis in Europe has prompted
what we are calling a coal comeback.
These countries were
really trying to get rid
of the most pollutant source of energy,
and in the short term at least,
it won't be able to do so.
In Germany, which has struggled
to phase out coal in recent years,
the energy crisis has
prolonged the practice
of razing small villages to mine
the lignite coal buried underneath.
Immerath was flattened to allow
for the expansion of this
massive open cast coal mine
which supplies a local power station,
that is one of the most
polluting in the whole of Europe.
So in the short term,
we are going to see
probably emissions rising,
and this can really
slow down European plans
to become climate neutral.
We are seeing also a nuclear
comeback in some countries.
Even in Germany
where nuclear has been such a taboo,
now the government has
decided to extend the life
of its remaining nuclear power plants.
Countries like the UK and Sweden
are also hoping to bring
more nuclear power online.
Though, any new plants are
years away from operation.
In the short term though,
nuclear is proving more of
a hindrance than a help.
In a case of spectacularly bad timing,
about half of France's
massive nuclear fleet
is currently shut down for repairs.
Normally with that huge
fleet of nuclear energy,
France has been a proud exporter
of power to the rest of Europe.
They're now expecting to
need imports of electricity,
and that changes the dynamic
for all the countries surrounding France.
So the UK, Germany, Spain,
everybody is going to have
to send imports to France,
and that means that they've got
less electricity themselves.
With no immediate way for Europe
to make up the shortfall in energy supply,
the other side of the
equation comes into play,
reducing demand.
Many countries have drawn
up guidelines for households
and businesses to voluntarily
reduce their energy use,
such as limiting heating in offices,
turning off lights at night,
and using clothes dryers
only at certain times of day.
The single most important measure
that European families can take
is reduce the thermostat down.
If we reduce the thermostat to 19,
probably something like 5 to 7%
of European gas demand could come off.
But much of the necessary
reduction in energy demand
won't need any special
push from governments.
It'll inevitably happen simply
because prices of energy
and everything else are so high.
We are seeing some
companies reducing output.
Some of them might not
ever be able to get back
to the production levels
from before the crisis.
Most of all the products
have risen in price.
I'm saying everything's
up, minimum 15, 20%.
Our margins are getting
smaller, but also the footfall
of customers coming in is getting smaller.
The people need more money to live
'cause everything's going up.
You know, like you say,
a lot of businesses,
they'll just call it a day.
Europeans are also
feeling the extra squeeze
from their home energy bills,
creating a dire economic situation
for many low and middle income people
and sparking cost of living
protests throughout Europe.
Don't pay UK means don't
pay your energy bills.
Our goal is to get a
million people striking.
In response, some countries have decided
to partially subsidize
their citizens' heating
and electric bills,
which could cost governments
hundreds of billions of euros
or pounds for this winter alone.
It also introduces problems
for the supply side of the equation.
The problem with the
subsidies and the price caps
for the families is that
they stop the price signal
from reaching household, and it means
that families do not have
the incentive to save,
to economize, to try to consume less
than they did last winter.
So it's a very difficult
and precarious equilibrium
in between helping families
and shielding them from
the impact of high prices
and letting the market
work and reduce demand
so there is enough gas to
make it through the winter.
One of the things that you could do
is protect the most vulnerable families,
the poor, the working class,
but at the moment, most European countries
is just literally protecting everyone.
Europe may not have found
the perfect solution
to the supply and demand puzzle,
but as winter approaches,
it's finally caught a few breaks.
Many countries have successfully filled up
their emergency stores of natural gas,
bringing gas prices down
from their late summer peak,
and forecasts are predicting
relatively mild winter temperatures.
Probably, Europe will be able to make it
through the winter.
The problem is what
happened next year into 2023
and the winter of 2023, 2024.
Without any Russian gas next year,
next winter looks absolutely horrendous.
There is not enough gas
out there in the LNG market
to replace imports of
Russia gas for a full year.
This is a permanent change
in the way that Europe has bought gas,
and that means permanent
higher gas and oil prices.
Many are hoping that
change can push Europe
in a direction it needs to go anyway
towards more renewable energy.
In light of this year's crisis,
a push towards renewables,
electrification, and energy
efficiency is more attractive
than it's ever been.
What we are seeing this
year is that fossil fuels
are not the way to have
a secure energy system.
That actually, clean energy
with renewables at its heart
are also going to be more secure.
It's not easy to roll out a
secure clean energy system.
Very, very difficult.
Lots and lots of work to
do, innovation to happen,
investment to happen, but it can be done.
Renewables are already
helping to turn the tide.
A study found that the wind
and solar capacity that
was added between March
and September alone saved
Europe the equivalent
of $11 billion in avoided gas imports.
We are seeing that authorities,
governments are raising
incentives for the construction
of more clean, wind, solar, power plants.
And Europe still is promising
and targeting to be climate
neutral in the mid-century.
Whilst fossil fuels have, of course,
powered incredible improvements
in living standards,
they've also led to war after
war, crisis after crisis.
But in the past, we've had no alternative.
This time, we have line of sight
towards an energy system
that is sustainable,
affordable, and secure.
And if there's going to be anything good
coming out of this year,
it is that vision and
accelerating towards it.